os tourner vers amandine et le cas des
étudiants et des étudiantes alors qui
dit étudiants dits petits boulots
notamment baby sitting dans votre cas là
quelle est la situation s'est
complètement le marché complètement mort
complètement asséché à la aujourd'hui ça
va mieux mais pas moins premier
confinement moi je me suis vu licenciés
et j'ai cherché à avoir de l'aide et
j'en ai pas eu parce que je faisais pas
assez d'heures sauf que le problème
c'est qu'un étudiant il peut pas faire
plus de 32 heures par mois c'est pas
possible
et du coup bas jeune et j'avais pas
d'argent et j'ai dû compter sur mes amis
sur ma famille pour m'aider et c'est
hyper compliqué mais là quelle est votre
quelle est votre situation quel est
votre source de revenus alors j'ai les
pensions alimentaires de mes parents et
aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé un nouvel emploi
mais depuis deux semaines trois semaines
et du coup ma situation s'améliore mais
j'ai peur parce que c'est encore du baby
sitting
et si je me retrouve comme au premier
confinement après avoir de travail
ben je sais pas comment je vais faire
parce que c'était limite si je pouvais
plus manger pendant le premier
confinement mais quels ont été les
effets concrets du confinement et même
du déconfinement sur le baby sitting
parce que c'est très délicat on
construit des enfants on peut on peut
craindre des deux côtés d'ailleurs les
parents peuvent craindre pour l'enfant
le baby sitter ou l'abbé visiteuse voilà
peut craindre d'être contaminé aussi
comment ça se passait alors au début
mars que sur l'aspect recel sauf que à
un moment donné on a coupé court à mon
contrat avant son terme et du coupage et
plus touchées chômage partiel du jour au
lendemain on m'a prévenu un jour et
j'étais même pas aux grands et l'été
j'ai cherché du travail il le vit sting
j'ai même chercher ailleurs pour vous
dire et j'ai rien trouvé
bah moi il n'y avait rien du tout alors
que à la rentrée faut savoir qu'un
étudiant il doit débourser s'il habite
seule chute de 2000 euros à la rentrée
de septembre 2020 moi j'ai pas d'argent
j'ai dû faire un prêt pour pouvoir payer
mes bouquins payer mes fournitures pour
payer ma nourriture
je comprends même pas à quel moment j'en
suis arrivée là
au début ça allait bien et puis
pou fé allait mal mais j'imagine que
c'est pas un cas isolé que parmi vos
camarades ya beaucoup de personnes dans
les mêmes difficultés peut-être encore
pire même peut-être bien effectivement
j'ai des amis pareils ils ont vu perdre
leur job leur seule source de revenus
pour pour certains alors que déjà il y
en avait j'en connais qui étaient dans
des huit mètres carrés tout seul pendant
trois mois qui peut-être ont perdu des
gens qui en plus ont perdu leur job pain
je sais même pas comment aujourd'hui ils
sont encore debout parce que déjà les
aides psychologiques on en parle on en
parle pas assez dans les facultés
alors qu'on en a besoin on dit c'est dur
d'avoir 20 en 2020 au près en fait foi
voire 20 pour le comprendre ce que c'est
on n'a plus de vie sociale on à moi par
exemple j'ai perdu quelqu'un de ma
famille de la de l'aco vide j'ai perdu
mon job
j'étais hébergé chez des amis
enfin je pensais pas me retrouver à
cette situation la santé est ma vie et
je suis pas du tout la seule et en plus
de ça les aide et n'étaient pas là ce
que madame la ministre nous dit on à des
aides mais il faut faire plus de 32
heures par mois vont bénéficier mais ça
change tout on ne peut pas faire 32
heures c'est pas possible
et il faut avoir été déclaré oui la
vérité vraie c'est que le baby sitting
fait partie de tout voir métiers de la
forme elle ne touche pas ses paroles ne
sont pas déclarés tout les milliers de
personnes qui sont dans le secteur
informel non touchés rien rien du tout
pendant ni le premier compliment est
juste une dernière question sur un point
que vous avez soulevé
on en parle peut être pas assez au sujet
du confinement c'est que des étudiants
doivent rester des semaines et des mois
dans des espaces extrêmement réduits
extrêmement confiné avec tous les effets
psychologiques et parfois psychiatrique
que ça implique oui bah oui jdd j'ai un
ami qui est resté trois mois dans un
lieu mètres carrés dans sa cité nu
astaire on a eu du mal à le faire sortir
des confirmands moi je pensais que il
allait courir dans la rue n'en a pas du
tout moi tout crois moi tout seul et
j'ai eu la chance quand même d'avoir un
grand appartement que mes amis
mon permis d'avoir lui c'était du mètre
carré je ne sais pas si vous imaginez
mais c'est rien quoi fait seul rien
faire ou à essayer de travailler mais
c'est travailler et essayer de suivre
les courants tels andy essentielle quand
on fait du droit
c'est hyper compliqué je sais même pas
si mon année je l'arrêté
l'année dernière on a réussi à avoir six
mois en présentiel 6 mois indice temps
ciel là on commence l'année du distance
elle et ça enfin si ça continue jusqu'à
la fin de l'année
franchement très honnêtement je ne sais
pas c'est moi personnellement et d'autre
on va y arriver